okay so uh this is on the eight count
suby um first I
think my my mind is always like
why why this F in
set
um you know I think that a lot of
teachers teach with like Legacy in mind
and they may you know they want to live
forever to me it's a fear of
death and ultimately a spiritual
immaturity so in a in a recent post when
I said uh sand Mandela for those who
don't know um these sand Mandela are
made painstakingly and then they're
wiped away immediately what I was noting
was the impermanence of it uh not the
magic of the mon
[\h__\h] that [\h__\h] okay get over yourself
you're going to [\h__\h]
die you're here to reach communion with
God everything is in a state of
impermanence and [\h__\h] grow
up so I watch
these people who don't really have a
spiritual ieto they have a fear of
death they're going to mask up and and
vaccine and all that
[\h__\h] and uh they're going to train
gently it it all goes together they're
going to seek power over you so they're
going to make sets they're going to make
monuments and talking to some of you you
do
have these sons of gods
that their followers will make monuments
of them but there's more sons of gods
that you never heard
of because they did not have this fear
of death they leave no monuments they
make S sand
mandelas so these teachers make these
sets they're very strange take for
example
Cha's 36
Joe there's not [\h__\h] 36 there's like
48 of
them like what the
[\h__\h] cuz Saito said there's 36
Joe why'd he get the number 36 you trace
trace it back somewhere and you got some
[\h__\h] numerologist that's just trying
to get rid of his insecurity by finding
some secret to the
universe and that's where you get these
magic numbers
no Grace comes through this seeking of
power my way is a way of
self-abandonment
so you have this eight count subber and
you're like why why eight why not seven
why not
12 but everyone wants to make a big deal
out of it eight there's
eight you're doing number four wrong
I've seen people mix up four and three
and two and one who gives a
[\h__\h] the fact that they're mixed up is
telling you this ain't
[\h__\h] so I'm not
fencing cuz I don't even have a partner
I'm not getting better internally
because there's so much other [\h__\h] that
takes away from the internal
aspects I'm not practicing KY and Ike I
don't even have a
partner there's so many better ways of
doing any of the things that you might
get out of the set I'm not getting
stronger I why am I doing this when you
look at it you just have fear of death
man just a monument
you're trying to collect things like
pharaohs would shove [\h__\h] in the tombs
want to live for
forever so there is no there's no why to
this there's no
why and once you realize that I think
you're
free of someone else's fear of
death and and you should play with it so
it makes
sense now the reasoning that I got on
the
eight which is obviously [\h__\h] is
that these are all the ways that you can
do Shon nag it's just not true there's
an infinite amount of ways that you can
do Shon
Naga but I think it's
important that if you're going to make
it a body art
technique then you should move the way
that you do in body art that means no
double
pivoting that means no rotation of the
body when the line of gravity is between
the
feet that means you have to have a
ground vector and most importantly on
because there's so much rotation in
here that you have to to know how to get
on the other
side of the Y Apex of a
curve which you always need to do in
Shon
nugget but they don't
do n out of 10
times so let's just kind of experiment a
little bit as I make this this point to
identify where's the single Pivot Point
where's the grounding foot
how to keep your line of gravity on a
single pivot point and how to get to the
other side of the Y
apex of the articulation degree I'll
show you this stuff
okay uh of course we have to always keep
the harmonies between the joints so
we're not going to stand in this goofy
stance not have our arches cave in not
torque our knees all that stuff is
[\h__\h] because we're rotating
uh your yang foot is going to drill down
on the ball of the foot okay and the yin
foot is pretty much who cares what the
yin foot is doing it as long as it stays
in the harmonies between the foot the
knee and the qual so let's get into
this
um more
important than the
set is to realize there is a c C
footwork in there and that footwork is
universal to all of your
Pon but it's not in chiba's lineage it's
not there if you do it that way you're
not going to see the footwork okay but
the footwork
is
that you're going to take weight from in
this case my back
foot I'm going to e me put weight onto
the new front foot and then rotate
drilling down on that ball the
foot so I
say if you really want the most out of
this set you forget the set and you
would do this footwork instead you have
a line that you use at a as a reference
point slide across shift your weight
onto that foot drill that foot down such
that you pull the Y foot across that
line drop down shift
across shift over turn and you pull the
yin foot across the line so again you
don't need a line you can do this this
way we do this constantly in
Keon so for example it is is at the
beginning of your ten
con it is at the beginning of your isido
ten
con it's in your EO starting Bo right
there on the hip on the hip turn itet
you just didn't turn it all the way it's
everywhere okay what is
it you're just going to shift weight
drill down bring the other leg with you
in the h that's all you're doing boom
boom boom
boom
boom okay we're going to try this for a
while and then we'll come back with more
details all right so if you're doing
count
three you're going to 10 con so you're
going to
T lot of people
have their weight in between their legs
their line of
gravity and they double pivot my weights
here in the middle and then they swing
around and go like
this looks like
this okay this never
works we've done many videos on this
that when your line of gravity is
between your Bas of support you can
stand on this side of
me okay and you're just going to hold my
ghee and he's going to pull that way
okay and when i t con in the middle of
that you're going to lose your
base we've done one with Leah with the
belt around her we did one
recently that line of him pulling my he
would also be his Mass just the mass
alone okay it doesn't work it's
incorrect you have to establish that
single Pivot Point on that
foot then this foot goes
by Ono ten con it's going to be the same
thing so you coming around this
way hold don't turn
here you have to shift onto this foot
and and then do the
turn what you're trying to do is avoid
that double
pivot because that puts your line of
gravity in the middle you have to shift
weight onto that leg you do that move we
just did and then you step back how far
you can't lose the six
harmonies here good enough you doing
your Shido tank con same thing in
up you're not going to go
over this because turn out on the left
side especially as you come
around so that you're not all weirded
out on this which is even more Awkward
because your left hand is f okay so you
can work
tcon or we 10
con doesn't matter does not matter but
don't undo the six harmonies keep your
foot your knee and your claw in
alignment careful when you work the left
side you get more twist okay we'll play
with that
[Music]
now so if I'm doing sh and I do it the
other
way this turn here is very weak
[Music]
now if I got there and I double pivot
you can see that I am on one
side I'm on the wrong side of the circle
on my hands what usually happens is the
UK walks backwards and gets in place
with
[\h__\h] you have to turn turn step into
place come back onto this foot now I'm
on the other
side turn on this
foot first move then you step back then
you're going to Pivot on that front
foot on the other
[Music]
side pivot by w on this
side and now what is in the
form so turn and I have to get back on
that side I can't go like this and turn
double pivot I have to get back on this
side now I'm ready to me boom into the
for so we'll
do
this shift boom get into this from back
on this
side okay let's play with that nothing
changes on Theo tank I go this way and I
come on this side of that young
aex don't go here in
turn you're not there you have to come
back on this foot he did in
place which means you have to single
pivot
Bo boom then you
can okay let's try that
one all right the
set is basically a grid so you work the
180 and the 90 that's
all and so if Shon Naga is my
justification for the
set even if I agree that there's only
eight Shon nag which I don't
this is not how we should be doing kihon
waza kihon waza should always rotate the
fight okay so he's coming in and as he
comes in I'm always
rotating if I'm going to do the
verion then I still have to
or I go to the right and he goes to the
left following my angle of deviation
angle of
deflection and you're here is where you
would find
the okay I go this
way then I can
make a smaller rotation but did step
this way
[Music]
I'm not going to
do this
stuff
no ridiculous
okay um lastly human tendency to slur
diction you can see this even on one is
someone skiing like that in prep for the
cut your ski should
be
straight
in and you can do that if you shift on
that
foot so here I am at the end of number
one hold the tip two hands okay and I
should drive
in boom and have the C
projection in
there pke you
project then the turn in the cut okay if
you double
pivot you're going to go here and you're
like this you see and that's you don't
get [\h__\h]
there your
ski should be a
ski there's your cut
okay but I do think that double pivoting
the no- grounding foot and not getting
past on the other side of the yin apex
of the articulation of the
term that's the most important thing
double
pivoting line of gravity in the middle
of your feet while you're
rotating
terrible and should be avoided at all
costs so if I wanted to work what was in
the a counts the
booty I would and we do this drill
instead this drill
instead shman
subi our bulin
sets
instead with
partner and then Shaga itself you can
get way more out of all of that
versus let's see right count somebody
okay my
opinion so uh we've been practicing and
I don't think what I was saying was as
clear I don't just mean
that the the fight is rotating of course
I mean that but I don't stop rotating in
the fight okay and when you have this
sword form especially when you double
pivot and you go here you're going to be
going against the energy of the UK okay
so let's just fake it for a little bit
okay so I'm here I come over here and
then I go like this right here you are
fighting the inertia okay and then you
have to overpower that to get that to go
okay so do that side
again here and you would never get here
real but let's say you do and you come
around here and now you're starting to
pull that
energy to get it to go here which your
UK will reconcile by stepping back for
you
okay this is not the art okay so let's
say I'm going to go around he's going to
go around
me all right do number
four it's not that I come here and then
reverse it pull on
him he keeps going around
me that's going to give us a couple
things if I'm doing a back break fall we
requiring you to do back break fall
which way should your Center be going
forward forward okay so you go like
this it's not going
forward see then everything gets faked
here your Center is going to go forward
you see all
right
okay and that can't be in the sword
form so if sh Naga is my justification
for the set
whatever okay